[موسيقى]
احييكم مشاهدينا مساء الخير انا ميسون
نواهد واقدم لكم اخبار الساعه كالعاده الى
العناوين
الهدنه تدخل حيز التنفيذ في السودان
وحماتي يستبقها بالتعهد بعدم التراجع
المرشح الرئاسي السابق سنان اوجان يتحدى
الانقسامات داخل تحالفه ويعلن دعما ثمينا
لايردوغان في جوله الاعاده
بعد هجوم بلغراد روسيا تتهم اوكرانيا
بالتخريب وقائد فاغنيل يفتح النار مجددا
على القاده العسكريين
وبعد اسابيع من انهاء حاله الطوارئ حول
كورونا الصحه العالميه تحذر العالم من
جديد وتقول استعدوا الان للوباء المقبل
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا قبل ان نبدا اخبار الساعه وقبل
ان نذهب تحديدا الى السودان سنتوقف مع هذه
الصور الملحميه لمدينه بخمه المدمره دمار
شاملا من
الى بخموت قرنان ومدينتان ودمار واحد
متابع
[موسيقى]
اول ملف في اخبار الساعه من السودان حيث
دخلت هدنه سبعه ايام حيز التنفيذ والتي
توصل اليها طرف الصراع في مدينه جده
السعوديه برعايه سعوديه امريكيه ومع ذلك
استبق قائد قوات الدعم السريع مثل هذه
الهدنه بالتصعيد حيث قال ان قواته لن
تتراجع عن موقفها الا بانهاء ما وصفه
بالانقلاب حملت اتهم الجيش بنشر الفوضى
باطلاق سراح المساجين من جميع السجون
بولايه الخرطوم بمنفهم قاده النظام السابق
نؤكد ان تمسك قوات الدعم السريع باستعاده
التحول الديمقراطي وانهاء الحلقه الشريره
التي دمرت السودان
الاندلابين يريدون تكرار تجربه الثلاثين
عام الماضيه نحن نديم قص المدنيين
والمستشفيات والمصانع وباقي البنيه
التحتيه بالطائرات والمدافع الصغيره على
الارواح البريئه التي فقدناها الشعب
السوداني الى الانتباه الى مخدرات الفلول
وحملات التضليل التي تهدف الى توسيع دائره
الحرب لن نتراجع الا بلا هذا الانقلاب
ومحاكمه كل من اجر في حق الشعب السوداني
والعوده الى المسار الديمقراطي
[موسيقى]
وفي احاطته بجلسه الامن الدولي قال
المبعوث الامي الى السودان فولكس انه لن
يمر يوم بدء النزاع في السودان دون قتال
بين الجيش والدعم السريع نستمر
لم يمر يوم بدون قتال بين الجيش والدعم
السريع منذ الخامس عشر من ابريل ونحو 900
شخص قتلوا بينهم اطفال بسبب الاشتباكات في
السودان واكثر من مليون شخص اضحو مشردين
بسبب استمرار العنف والكثير من السودانيين
حوصروا في منازلهم ويفتقرون الى الامدادات
اود ان اشير ايضا الى ان القتال ادى
لاندلاع توترات قبليه واثنيه خاصه في
دارفور طرف النزاع في السودان انتهكال
قانون الانساني الدولي
ماساه داخل ماساه هكذا تبدو بالصوره
بالنسبه للسودانيين عدد من المواطنين
فقدوا جوازات سفرهم التي كانت داخل
السفاره الامريكيه خلال فتره الحرب وذلك
بسبب اتلافها خلال عمليات الاجلاء قصه
احباط وعجز امام فقدان وثيقه كان يمكن ان
تستخدم للخروج من اتون النزاع
هكذا صار حاله يخيم على شكله الاسى
لم يتوقع الحر شرف الدين الشاب العشريني
ان ينتهي طموحه بمثل صدمه كهذه
فبعد ان سعى لتحقيق احلامه بدراسه
الماجستير في احدى الجامعات الامريكيه
بات الان يواجه احدى ماسي الحرب وصدماتها
القاسيه في السودان وقدمت
في السفاره يوم اثنين اربعه فالدوني
الابوينت يوم 11/4
وفعلا مشيت الانترفيو والحمد لله كانت
الفيزا
وبعد ما رجعتها تابعته في السيستم بتاعهم
بعد يوم كانت الفيزا يشوت يعني اتطبعت في
الجواز وكان المفروض استلم الجواز مطبوع
فيه الفيزا يوم 16/4 او يوم 18/4
لم يقف عاجزا عند ذلك بل بذل كل ما في
وسعه لايجاد حل ما ثاني حاول تراسل معه
منشوف
اي اجراء ممكن
يطلعنا من البلد فبيقى ما عندنا لا عندنا
من البلد وفي نفس الوقت ما يعني زول تفاجا
صراحه اتصدم انه لا يقدر يبدا دراسته في
الوقت المحدد ولا حيقدر يطلع من البلد
بعدها ان الباسورد للاسف تدمر لم يكن وحده
من تضرر من هذا الاجراء اذ نشرت نيويورك
تايمز الامريكيه مقالا مفصلا يضم اخرين
تمزقت احلام الكثيرين هنا بسبب اتلاف
السفاره الامريكيه ما بداخلها من جوازات
قبيل عمليه الاجلاء وهو بروتوكول شاركته
سفارات اوروبيه اخرى
واضعه من شملهم ذلك في قدر بروتوكول
بالنسبه للسفارات وماساه بالنسبه لاصحاب
الجوازات
المقداد حسن لقناتي العربيه والحدث
اندرمان
[موسيقى]
في تركيا وبعد طول انتظار وتكهنات اعلن
المرشح الخاسر في الجوله الاولى من
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والملقب بصانع الملوك
سنان اوغان انه سيدعم الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان في جوله الحسن من الانتخابات
والتي سيتنافس فيها الاخير مع مرشح
المعارضه كمالك الاجداد اوغلو في 28 من
مايوغان اوضح ان قرار دعم اردوغان بعد
التشاور مع قاده تحالف الاجداد الذي مثله
في الانتخابات واضاف ان المعارضه التركيه
لم تقدم له اسبابا مقنعه لكي يدعم مرشحها
في الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات الذي حصل
على 5% من الاصوات في الجوله السابقه يعول
عليه اردوغان لحسم السباق لصالحه
[موسيقى]
اعلن اننا سندعم السيد رجب طيب اردوغان
مرشح الرئاسه عن تحالف الشعب في الجوله
الثانيه من الانتخابات ادعو كل الناخبين
الذين صوتوا لنا في الجوله الاولى لدعم
السيد اردوغان في جوله الاعاده فشل تحالف
الامه في تحقيق النجاح الكافي ضد تحالف
الشعب الذي يتولى السلطه منذ 20 عاما كما
انهم لم يتمكنوا من تقديم منظور يقنعنا
بالمستقبل والاهم انهم فشلوا في تامين
الاغلبيه البرلمانيه وتجاهلت عامل
الاستقرار
لكن سرعان ما برزت الانقسامات داخل تحالف
الاجداد الذي تزعمه اوغانا رئيس حزب الظفر
وميت اوزاك قال ان قراره اوغان شخصيه ولا
يمثل التحالف واضاف ان التحالفات تخلى عن
اتخاذ القرارات والتحرك بشكل مشترك لم
يتوقف الامر عند ذلك الحد تشير تقارير
محليه تركيا الى ان اوزاك قريب من اعلان
دعمك ردا على قرار
ووراء هذا القرار اسباب فندها اوغان
لتبرير دعمه لاردوغان تلخصات حول مبادئ
اتفق عليها وهي محاربه الارهاب ووضع جدول
زمني لاعاده اللاجئين وتعزيز مؤسسات
الدوله التركيه لكن مشاهدينا يبقى السؤال
الى اي مرشح ستذهب غالبيه اصوات مليونين
وثمانمائه الف ناخب التي حصل عليها اوغان
لان جزءا من ناخبيه كان يعتزم عدم التصويت
لادوغان الذي يتولى السلطه منذ 20 عاما
اما كريش وفي اول تصريح له بعد قرار اوغان
ندد بقرار اوغان وشدد على ان هدفه انقاذ
تركيا من الارهاب واللاجئين على حد قوله
في اخبار الساعه سنتابع بعد قليل المستشار
الالماني يقول ان اعاده انتخاب بايدن افضل
من عوده ترامب
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد نتابع في اخبار الساعه
من الشان الاوكراني والروسيه افاد حاكم
بالجراد الروسيه بان مجموعه تابعه للجيش
الاوكراني وصفها بالتخريبيه دخلت الاراضي
الروسيه بالمقاطعه وقال الحاكم ان القوات
الامنيه بالتعاون مع حرس الحدود والامن
الفيدرالي اتخذت الاجراءات الضروريه حيال
هذه المجموعه من جهته اعتبر ان هذه
العمليه هدفها ابعاد الانظار عن باخمت اما
اوكرانيا نفت ان تكون لها اي علاقه بهذا
الحادث وقال مستشار الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
بخيال ان بلاده تتابع باهتمام الاحداث في
بلغراد وتدرس الوضع الراهن
هذا الحادث في بلغراد فتح الباب لهجوم
جديد من رئيس مجموعه
بحق القاده العسكريين الروس حيث اتهمهم
بشكل غير مباشر بالتقصير
في الواقع هناك حرب مستمره اليوم تحولت
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه الى حرب شامله
ليست هذه المره الاولى في مناطق بيل جرود
وكورسكو وبريانس التي نشهد فيها انفجارات
وقتل اشخاص
من موسكو ينضم الى مراسل العربيه عبد
الجواد الرشد عبد الجواد اهلا بك معنا
هناك انباء يعني ونحن نتحدث معك في هذه
اللحظات بانه هناك
تدري ان هناك قصف تنفذها القوات الروسيه
في بيلجارود وعلى كل حال نريد ان نعرف
بلغراد ولا بالجرود لانها تكتب بالقرود
ولكن نسمع الروس يقولونها
مساء الخير ميسون نعم صحيح ما تقولين هي
بيل جراد المدينه المتخمه للاراضي
الاوكرانيه الانباء الوارده من هناك ما
تتحدثين عنه صحيح يعني هي معلومات عن سماع
اصوات عاليه في المدينه تقارير ترجح بان
هذه هي الاصوات ناجمه عن ضربات تنفذها
القوات المسلحه الروسيه نحو الاراضي
الاوكرانيه او مناطق حدوديه من الجانب
الاوكراني نعم بالفعل ميسون يعني هم
ثمانيه جرحى نتيجه هذا العمل ودخول هذه
الفرقه من محاور ثلاثه من مقاطعه بيلغراد
عبر الغابات تحدثت عنها حكومه بلغراد
رسميا دون وقوع اي قتلى هذه المدينه طبعا
ميسون ليست المره الاولى او هذا الاقليم
الذي يشهد مثل هذه الاعمال لكن هي المره
الاولى التي تصل فيها شده الاعمال الى هذه
الدرجه هو اقتحام من مناطق مختلفه ادى
لهذا العدد من الجرحى طبعا في الاخبار
العاجله فيما يخص قضيه بيل جراد بان حكومه
المدينه قامت باجلاء العديد من سكان مناطق
القرى المجاوره والمنتخمه للاراضي
الاوكرانيه العدديه يدور يعني عن اعداد
كبيره من تلك المناطق تم اجلائهم نحو
الداخل الروسي او داخل هذا الاقليم نلاحظ
ايضا ميسون بان هذه المنطقه تتعرض خلال
الاربع والعشرين ساعه الماضيه الى طلبات
مكثفه ليله الامس قامت مسيره برمي طبعا
عبوه ناسفه سقطت على مبنى حكومي وادت الى
اشتعال نيران كثيره طبعا تم اخمادها بعد
قرابه ساعتين من اندلاع السنه اللهب في
سماء المدينه وهذا الشيء طبعا تم تداوله
بشكل واسع كالنار في الهشيم على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي وخاصه في تيليجرام
روسيا روسيا روسيا قالت بانه هذا عمل
تخريبه وطبعا اتهمت اوكرانيا ولكن
اوكرانيا نفذ ذلك هل هناك اي تصريح بعد
نفي اوكرانيا وماذا ايضا عن ريجوجين الذي
مازال يساعد تجاه القاده العسكريين الروس
بايجاز لو سمحت معنا 30 ثانيه
يعني هي حرب التصريحات تستمر بما يخصك على
منطقه المسؤوليه بين موسكو وكيف موسكو
رسميا لم تجب عن هذا الشيء لكن طبعا عاد
من جديد واتهم يعني العديد من المسؤولين
الروسي بتقصيرهم بما يخص القضايا الامنيه
وحمايه البلاد خاصه في المناطق الحدوديه
التي تبدا من وتنتهي فيراستوف تفضل يا
ميسون شكرا لك
هذه المعلومات وعلى الالتزام بالوقت ايضا
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
اعود الى اسطنبول مع مراسل العربيه زيدان
زنجلو زيدان اهلا بك معنا هذا الانشقاق في
تحالف الاجداد ماذا لدينا من تفاصيل حوله
طبعا اعطى وجيه اصواته الى اردوغان ولكن
ايضا هناك احزاب اخرى معه في هذا التحالف
يقال بانه ستعطي الى كمايكلتش ماذا في
التفاصيل
نعم تحيه ميسون لك ولجميع المشاهدين لا شك
ان هذا اليوم كان متوقعا ان سنان اوغان
سيودلي بهذا التصريح ويدعم الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان بخلاف بقيه احزاب تحالف الاجداد
طبعا هو تحالف صغير لم يستطع دخول
البرلمان وحصل على اثنين فاصله اربعه من
الاصوات وهذا مناعه من دخول البرلمان كونه
لن يتجاوز العتبه الانتخابيه في
الانتخابات البرلمانيه لكن على العكس سنان
اوغان حصل على خمسه فاصله واحد في المئه
تقريبا من الاصوات وهذه النسبه دفعت
اردوغان وايضا كالجدار اوغلو
للقائه ومحاوله كسب دعم اوغان في المحصله
او ان دعم اردوغان لكن بقيه الاحزاب
ونتحدثون عن حزب النصر او الظفر الذي
ينتمي اليه اوغان وايضا حزب العداله وهو
حزب صغير ايضا حصل على 0.2% من الاصوات في
الانتخابات برلمانيه يبدو انه ليس على
وفاق مع
اوغنفي في قرار دعم اردوغان لذلك حزب
العداله اعلن مسبقا انه سيدعم كلجدار
اوغلو ايضا مساء هذا اليوم التقى اميت
اوزدار رئيس حزب النصر
بينهما ومن المنتظر ان يدلب ببيان صحفي
يوم غد الثلاثاء في الساعه الحاديه عشره
بالتوقيت المحلي بالمحصله يعني اليوم هذا
التحالف تحالف الاجداد وتفكك بشكل فعلي
بعد اعلان نتائج انتخابات البرلمانيه
والرئاسيه وبالتالي الاصوات التي حصل
عليها سنان اوغانيا اكثر من الاصوات التي
حصل عليها التحالف استنادا لعده ظروف خدمت
اوغان وبالتالي حصل على هذه النسبه
العاليه النسبه الحقيقيه لاوغان هي 2.4 هي
النسبه التي حصل عليها التحالف لكن حوالي
3% من الاصوات
محسومه لاردوغان هل الشارع التركي يعني
وال احزاب السياسيه تعتبر ذلك
نعم ميسون لا شك انه بعد انتهاء الجوله
الاولى
واستطاع وتمكن اردوغان من الحصول على
الاغلبيه البرلمانيه هذا اعطاه نقطه
اضافيه اكبر تجاه الجوله الثانيه هناك
خشيه في الشارع او لا يرغب الناخب التركي
بحسب ما نسمع ونقرا بان يكون هناك تعارض
ما بين السلطه التنفيذيه والسلطه
التشريعيه بالتالي فرص اردوغان اكبر بكثير
ايضا ما ساعد اردوغان او فرص اردوغان في
الجوله الثانيه هو ردود الفعل الغاضبه من
حزب الشعب الجمهوري الذي يتزعمه كمالك
الجدار اوغلول اللاسيه باتجاه متضرري
الزلزال والاجراءات التي قامت بها
البلديات التابعه لهذا الحزب المعارض
تحدثون تحديدا عن بلديه تيكردار التي طردت
متضرري الزلزال الذين كانوا يقطنون في
اماكن ايواء مؤقته بسبب موقفهم الذي
ظهر في الانتخابات المؤيد لاردوغان ايضا
بعض المنظمات المنظمات الداعمه لحزب الشعب
الجمهوري اوقف الدعمها والاعمال الاغاثيه
التي كانت تقدمها في المناطق المنكوبه
كرده فعل على تصويت هذه المناطق لاردوغان
بالتالي هذا خلق حاله من الاستياء اردوغان
استغل هذه النقطه وتوجه الى مناطق الزلزال
وعد بتقديم المساعدات وتعهد بتقديم
المساعدات لمن تخلى عنهم حزب الشعب
الجمهوري كما قال بالتالي نتحدث عن ان
الامور تتجه بشكل كبير لاردوغان الا اذا
كان هناك مفاجاه في الجوله الثانيه وهذا
الموضوع لا يمكن التكهم به حتى الان لحين
صدور نتائج الانتخابات في 28 من مايو
صل العربيه زيدان من اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
بالعوده مشاهدينا الى تطورات الحرب في
اوكرانيا فمع اتهامات روسيا بل لكافه
بابعاد الانظار عما يحدث بعدها حادثه
بلغراد ترى موسكو في سقوط المدينه انتصارا
استراتيجيا اما بالنسبه لاوكرانيا ربما
تكون فرصه جديده فبحسب صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز ان ادعاء روسيا بتحقيق النصر يصدل
الستار عن اكثر المعارك دمويه في اوكرانيا
اما اوكرانيا فتقول بان هذه التطورات تمثل
فرصه مؤاتيه لاخذ زمام المبادره وقلب
الموازين المحيط بخمط وضواحيها التي
تحاصرها الان قواتك
التي باتت مدمره بشكل كامل بعد اشهر من
القتال قد لا تساعد بالضروره موسكو في
تحقيق هدفها في فرد السيطره الكامله على
دون باس وفق الصحيفه فالقوات الاوكرانيه
ستكثف قصفها لاماكن تمركز القوات الروسيه
بالمدينه فضلا عن الميزه التي سيفرضها
استلام كاف لمقاتلات حديثه مثل اف 16
لكن السؤال الان مشاهدينا ماذا بعد
استيلاء موسكو على باخموت على الصعيد
الميداني بحسب سي ان بي سي روسيا تعتزم
استخدام بخموت بعد السيطره عليها كمركز
لوجستي تنقل من خلاله الامدادات الى
قواتها في المنطقه ما سيساعدها على دفع خط
المواجهه نحو عمق اوكرانيا وتحديدا للزحف
نحو مدن اكبر مثل كراماتورز كواس لوبيان
وجميعهم يقعون باتجاه الغرب في دانيتسكو
ومع ذلك يرى محللون عسكريون ان الامر لن
يكون بهذه السهوله فمثلا مع انسحاب القوات
الاوكرانيه لمناطق دفاعيه في مناطق في
كراماتورس والتي تم تجهيزها على مدى
ثمانيه اعوام ستعطي ميزه لكاف في خط
المواجهه فكرمتورس تقع على ارض اعلى
وتتمتع بقدرات دفاعيه اكثر من باخموت ومن
المرجح ان يكون اي تقدم في هذه المنطقه
دمويه بالنسبه للروس مق بما حدث في بخموت
مخاوف اوكرانيا ربما مشروعه من خساره
المزيد من المدن لكن الغرب لا يتقاسم هذه
المخاوف معها فمحللون يرون ان روسيا
استنفذت بالفعل الكثير من قواتها خلال
معركه بخموت وانا الاستيلاء على المدينه
وان كان ضرووريا الا انه غير كاف للتقدم
في دانياسك
ومع ذلك مشاهدينا الطريق لن يكون مفروشا
بالورود امام القوات الروسيه لما بعد سقوط
فما اعلان قائد مجموعه باغنير بيجوجين
انسحاب قواته بحلول يونيو المقبل من
المدينه تمهيدا لتسليمها للقوات الروسيه
لم يتوقف عن لغته الساخره من القياده
العسكريه الروسيه التي لطالما انتقدها حيث
قال اذا لم يكن هناك عدد كاف من وحدات
وزاره الدفاع لتسلم باخد سيتوجب تشكيل فوج
من الجنرالات ومنحهم الاسلحه وسيكون كل
شيء على ما يرام اشكاليه اخرى ستواجه
موسكو ما هي اعتزام قوات فاجنر ايقاف
المشاركه في العمليات العسكريه حتى
الانتهاء من فتره التعافي وتدريب وهي
الفتره التي لم يحددها بريغورجن التي لعبت
قواته الدوره الرئيسي على خط المواجهه في
الاثناء ايضا هناك تقارير استخباراتيه
تشير الى ان هناك تغييرات في الجيش الروسي
الى تشكيل قوات نخبه في سلاح الجو
استعدادا لمواجهه الهجوم المضاد التي تخطط
له
انتصار بنكهه الحذر اعلنت هوموسكو في
باخموت وان كان الاعتماد فيه على قوات
فاجنر للسيطره على تلك المدينه فقط فلا بد
لها من اعاده ترتيب صفوف القوات الروسيه
الرسميه باختصار القوات الروسيه تتغير
على مدى اشهر استنزفت روسيا قوات النخبه
التي عرفت
على خطوط القتال الاماميه تستعد عنها
اليوم بقوات شتورن وفق ما بينته وزاره
الدفاع البريطانيه مجموعه طيران من طراز
النخبه قد تشهد مبارزه قاسيه مع مقاتلات
اف 16 في سماء اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وحده مدعمه بمقاتلات الجويه
وطائراتها تتولى مهام الهجوم الارضي
تقدم حققته القوات الروسيه متوغله في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه طوال فتره الحرب
وقبلها في شبه جزيره القرم مكتسبات
ستحميها موسكو بكل السبل متركزه في نقاط
اساسيه معظمها جنوب اوكرانيا بحسب
خنادق وحواجز وتحصينات رصدتها البي بي سي
من خلال صور الاقمار الصناعيه لتحدد تمركز
نقاط الدفاع والتكتيكات الدفاعيه
جنوب اقليم زابوريا حيثما تزال المعارك
محتدمه هو مفتاح لبوابه شبه جزيره القرم
ونقطه هدف للهجوم المضاد الاوكراني
مطار برديانسك بقرب بحر ازوف والذي يعتبر
قاعده رئيسيه للمقاتلات الروسيه
كل منسك شماليه شبه الجزيره وديان كوي
التي تضم قاعده جويه روسيه بوابات اساسيه
للقرم بالاضافه لحمايه الطريق اي 105
الواصل بين ميليتو بول التي تسيطر عليها
روسيا وخر كيف الاوكرانيه
رعب انتشر قبل الان بين الدول الاوروبيه
الاعضاء في حلف النيتو من توسع روسيا على
حدودها الرعب بات الان من التورط في حرب
كبرى فكيف للحلف ان يواجه جيشا في طور
التحول ويخرج من معارك قاسيه لتشدد مجله
نيوز على ضروره احداث تغييرات على قوه
الحلف لمواجهه خصمها في الشرق الى عمر
العربيه
[موسيقى]
وحول اخر تطورات الصفقه المحتمله لمقاتلات
افته عشر وزير القوات الجويه الامريكيه ان
هذه المقاتلات ستتمركز في اوكرانيا بعد
تسليمها من الغرب مشيرا الى ان عمليه نقل
هذه الطائرات الى اوكرانيا ستستغرق عده
اشهر
[موسيقى]
المشاهدين الى الشان الامريكي وحول ازمه
سقف الدين يلتقي الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
ورئيس مجلس النواب كيفن ماكارتي في البيت
الابيض في لحظه محوريه تشهد مصارعه في
واشنطن للتوصل الى حل وسط بشان الميزانيه
ورفع الحد الاقتراض في الوقت المناسب
لتجنب تعثر فيدرالي مدمر من جانبه قلم
كارتي ان مكالمته الهاتفيه الاخيره مع
بايدن كانت مثمره وان المفاوضات بين
موظفيه وممثلين بيت الابيض تركز على خفض
الانفاق
لكن مشاهدينا يبقى سؤال مهم ماذا سيحدث
للعالم لو لم تسدد الولايات المتحده
ديونها في الوقت المحدد غالبيه المصادر
اتفقت على ان التاثير على الولايات
المتحده سيفوق ما حدث في عام 2011 حينما
اخرت الحكومه قرار رفع سقف الدين ليومين
قبل نفاذ الاموال على المدى القصير ستخسر
الولايات المتحده نصف مليون وظيفه وسينخفض
اقتصادها بنحو 0.6 من ناتجها القومي فيما
على النطاق العالمي فتجب هنا معرفه ثقل
الخزانه والديون الامريكيه في الاقتصاد
العالمي لمعرفه الاثر المخيف لعدم السداد
فنحو 500 مليار دولار من السندات
الامريكيه يتم تداولها يوميا في سوق
السندات وتشكل الاسهم الامريكيه ما نسبته
60% من قيمه الاسهم في العالم لذلك فان
اقل ما يقال عن تاثير التخلف عن السداد
انه
كارثي على الاقتصاد العالمي
[موسيقى]
في رد غير متوقع قال المستشار الالماني
انه يفضل الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن على
سلفه دونالد ترامب قال ردا على سؤال احد
التلاميذ خلال زيارته لمدرسه في برلين قال
انه يفضل ان يعاد انتخاب بايدن مره اخرى
في فتره ولايه ثانيه للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
وفي اخبار الساعه سنتابع بعد قليل بعد
اتهامات بعلاقته بالجاسوس الخارق علي
شمخان يترك منصبه في مجلس الامن القومي
الايراني
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد بعد اسابيع من انهاء
حاله الطوارئ الصحيه العالميه بشان كورونا
حتى مدير عام منظمه الصحه العالميه تدرس
حتى الدول على تنفيذ الاصلاحات اللازمه
للاستعداد للوباء المقبل
لا يمكن ان نترك كل هذا على الطريق ونمضي
اذا لم نجري التغييرات اللازمه فمن سيفعل
ذلك واذا لم نقم بها الان فمتى عندما يطرق
الوباء التالي الباب يجب ان نكون مستعدين
للاجابه بشكل حاسب وجماعي ومنصف من اجل
تعزيز التعاون الدولي اتفاق الوباء التزام
باننا لن نعود الى الحلقه القديمه من
الذعر والاهمال التي عرضت عالمنا للخطر
سنمضي قدما بالتزام مشترك لمواجهه
التهديدات المشتركه من خلال الاستجابه
الجماعيه
[موسيقى]
والان الى موضوع
في مجال الرقائق الالكترونيه المعروفه
باسم اشباه الموصلات فهو هذا الصراع ذات
اكثر وضوحا وفقه صحيفه الجاردن تنامي حرب
الرقائق لوحدها بعد ان حضرت الحكومه
الصينيه شراء المنتجات من شركه مايكرون
تكنولوجي اكبر شركه لتصنيع اشباه الموصلات
في الولايات المتحده والسبب يعود الى
اعتقاد الصين بان منتجات مايكرون تشكل
مخاطر علميه جسيمه على الامن القومي وفق
تقرير الصحيفه الولايات المتحده من جهتها
اوضحت انها ستعمل مع حلفائها لمعالجه ما
اسمته تشويها اسواق رقائق الذاكره بسبب
تصرفات الصين خصوصا بعدما اعلنت اداره
الفضاء الالكتروني الصينيه ان منتجات
صنعتها شركه مايكرون الامريكيه لم تجتاز
مراجعتها لامن الشبكات
الجانب الامريكيه على تصحيح تصوره للصين
ووقف التدخل في شؤوننا الداخليه وتقويض
سيادتنا وامننا ومصالحنا التنمويه
والالتقاء بالصين في منتصف الطريق واتخاذ
اجراءات عمليه لاعاده العلاقات الامريكيه
الصينيه الى المسار الصحيح
في المقابل استبعد مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه
في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل فك
الارتباط الاقتصادي مع الصين مؤكدا ان لا
احد في المجموعه الاوروبيه يخطط لذلك
لا احد في الكتله الاوروبيه يتحدث عن فك
الصله الاقتصاديه مع الصين لا احد يريد
ذلك قيمه التبادلات التجاريه بيننا وصلت
الى مليارين و700 مليون يورو يوميا
المناقشات تدور حول خفض الاعتماد المتزايد
على الصين لان هذا قد يكون محفوفا
بالمخاطر لكن لا احد مستعد لفك الارتباط
بين الاقتصاد الاوروبي والصيني
صراع اخر دخلته الصين والهدف تطوير شبكه
انترنت تعمل بالاقمار الصناعيه يمكنها
منافسه ستار لينك المنبوكه للملياردير
الامريكي ايلون ماسك الا ان طموح بكين
لبناء شبكه عريضه النطاق عبر الاقمار
الصناعيه يواجه عقبات من ضمنها قدره
الاطلاق المحدوده والحواجز التكنولوجيات
اكدت قدرتها على الحفاظ على اتصالات
انترنت عاليه السرعه في اوكرانيا رغم تلف
البنيه التحتيه للاتصالات السلكيه
واللاسلك في البلاد ما اظهر حاجه بكين الى
اساطيل مماثله من الاقمار الصناعيه تدور
بالقرب من الارض وتعرف باسم الابراج وفق
صحيفه
بدات فعلا بتشييد مواقع الاطلاق الجديده
على اراضيها وتوسعت في صناعه الاقمار
الصناعيه في البلاد خصوصا عبر شركات خاصه
[موسيقى]
في ايران وفي قرار مفاجئ عين الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيس امنا عاما جديدا
للمجلس الاعلى للامن القومي خلفا لعلي
شمخاني الذي تولى منصبه منذ نحو عشر سنوات
واستبعد مصدر ايراني ان يكون للتغيير في
قياده مجلس الامن القومي تاثير على سياسات
المجلس قائلا انه ربما تجري دراسه تعيين
شمخاني في منصب اكثر اهميه
لكن مشاهدينا ما اسباب هذا الاستبعاد
لشمخاني حتى الان لا اسباب معلنه لكن
بالعوده قليلا للوراء سنجد ان شمخانه
ارتبط اسمه في يناير الماضي بقضيه تجسس
اتهم فيها المسؤول الايراني علي رضا اكبر
الذي كان يحمل الجنسيه البريطانيه والذي
اعدمته السلطات الايرانيه بتهمه التجسس
لصالح بريطانيا السلطات الايرانيه اتهمت
حينها اكبر بلعب دور في اغتيال محسن فخري
زاده العالم النووي عام 2020 لكنها لم
تقدم ادله على هذه الاتهامات ما اثار موجه
اذانات دوليه واسعه لكن ما علاقه شمخاني
باكبر الذي لقب بالجاسوس الخارق رضا اكبر
يشتغل عده مناصب حساسه داخل دوائر صنع
القرار في ايران من ضمنها المجلس الاعلى
لان القومي وهو ما اثار موجه غضب داخليه
لما اعتبر تقصيرا واختراقا لهذه المؤسسه
الحساسه اذا ما هي السيناريوهات التي
تنتظر شمخاني بعد استبعاده
حسب موقع فرار القريب من الاصلاحيين فان
الرجل البالغ من العمر 67 عاما تنتظره
ثلاث سيناريوهات حول مستقبله السياسي
اولها مقعد في البرلمان خصوصا مع اقتراب
موعد الانتخابات اما الخطوه الاعلى التي
قد يخطوها شمخاني هي التنافس على رئاسه
الجمهوريه في عام 25 وذلك اذا صادق مجلس
الصيانه الدستور على اهليته اما السيناريو
الاخير والذي قد ينهي حياته السياسيه هو
التواري عن الانظار والبقاء في منزله لما
تبقى من حياته
متابعه لهذا الموضوع من دبي ينضم الى
الصحفي المختص في الشان الايراني مسعود
الفك مسعود اهلا بك معنا ما دلاله استبعاد
شمخاني في هذا التوقيت بالذات
تحياتي لك والمشاه الكرام ابلا شك علي
شمخاني كان يحجب على حشم روحه اي كان يحجب
على التيار المعتدل وحتى على التيار
الاصلاحي كما كان كما يسميه بعض
الاصوليين
بالاصلاح المختفي
كون الامر في دائره
المنافسه بين التيارات في داخل ايران وهذا
امر معروف طبيعي بين التيارات في داخل
السلطه الان السلطه في ايران هي
معظمها في واقع الان بيد الاصوليين من
السلطه التنفيذيه الى السلطه القضائيه
والى البرلمان الايراني هذا التنسيق يدى
يبدو بانه علي شمخان مكانته ليست فيه هذه
المجموعه الا ان المرشد بعد بعد اقالته
عينه مستشارا سياسيا له ايضا وعضوا في
مجمع تشخيص مصلحه النظام الى ان هذه
المناصب هي عاده مناصب روتينيه عندما
تنتهي مهام اي مسؤول كبير يتم
الى اي مدى موضوع عدم قمع يعني يتهم
شمخاني بانه لم يقمع المظاهرات التي خرجت
بعد مقتل مهسه امينه وايضا كما ذكرنا الان
في الخبر وهو ايضا عندما زج اسمه بموضوع
الجاسوس الذي اعتبر اكبر الجواسيس واعدم
علي رضا اكبري الى اي مدى هذا الاستبعاد
له علاقه بهذين الشانين
لو كانت مساله التجسس صحيحه مئه بالمئه
بالنهايه علشان ليس مسؤولا لو توقف شخص
جاسوس في داخل المؤسسه التي يعمل فيها وهو
لم يكن جاسوسه بل من كانت متوغلا هو
مساله هذه كان ضد الاحتجاجات بالعكس هو
كان ضد الاحتجاجات وسابقا ايضا ضد
احتجاجات 2019 الا انه اسلوبه ليس اسلوبا
متشددا مثل الاخرين معروف عليه شامخاني
يحتاج حتى يقنعوه على موقف يحتاج اقناعه
بالدلائل والمناقشه لديه 30 ثانيه مسعود
ما السيناريو الذي ينتظر مصير شمخاني
البعض يعتبر بانه شاب خاني حياته السياسيه
انتهت وهو شغل مناصب بما يكفي في داخل
ايران الا ان البعض يعتقد قد ينافس
ابراهيم رئيس في الانتخابات المقبله خاصه
سابقا ايضا رشح نفسه امام الرئيس الاصلاحي
محمد خاتمي ولكن لا اعتقد حظوظه ستكون
كبيره شكرا لك من دبي الصحفيه المختصه في
الشان الايراني مسعود الفك
[موسيقى]
بعد ان اغلقت الاف المخابز ابوابها في
مناطق عده في تونس اترع عدم توافر المواد
الاساسيه لصناعه الخبز قال الرئيس التونسي
قيس سعيد ان الخبز خط احمر للمواطن ولن
يتم السكوت عما وصفه بمحاولات تجويع الشعب
الخبز ايضا والمواد الاساسيه بالنسبه الى
المواطن خط احمر
وهناك جمله
من الدوائر واللوبيات التي تسعى الى تاجيج
الوضع
واسمائهم معروفه
والتعلم بهذا الخبز المصنف وغير المصنف
الى اخر ذلك كله غير مقبول
خبز المواطن بالفعل لابد ان يتوفر وتتوفر
المواد الاساسيه بطبيعه الحال اليوم في
وزاره الفلاحه وفي ديوان الحبوب وعلى
ديوان الحبوب ان يكون في مستوى المرحله
وعلى كل الادارات في تونس ان تكون في
مستوى المرحله لانه لا يمكن
ان نواصل التعامل مع هؤلاء
ونتركهم يعبثون بقوت المواطن ويعبثونه
بحياته في كل اوجهها في كل مستويات بعد
اكثر من سته عشره ساعه من التحليق في
الفضاء دخل رائده الفضاء السعوديان ريان
برناوي وعلي القرنيه الى محطه الفضاء
الدوليه كانت اكتملت مناوره الالتحام
للمركبه دراغون التي حملت بغناوي وعلي مع
محطه الفضاء الدوليه
[موسيقى]
اليوم احنا قادرين الحمد لله نوصل الفضاء
بشهاب وشاب سعوديين مسلمين عرب قادرين
ينقلون رؤيتنا ويرفعون اسمنا في هل العالم
كله والله شيء عظيم جدا شعور بالفخر شعور
باعتزاز وطني يوصل للمكان هذه وباذن الله
منها لاشياء افضل وافضل هذه مجرد بدايه بس
بصفه امراه ومواطنه سعوديه اشعر بفخر
وسعاده بالغين اليوم انه حدث تاريخي وكلنا
متحمسون حقا لتوجه رائدى الفضاء لمحطه
الفضاء الدوليه لاول مره
[موسيقى]
فرض الاتحاد الاوروبي غراما على شركه ميسي
ملكه منصه فيسبوك بشان انتهاك الخصوصيه
وطريقه التعاملها مع بيانات المستخدمين
الغرامه بلغت مليارا و300 مليون دولار
وحدد الاتحاد للشركه مده خمسه اشهر كموعد
نهائي لوقف نقل بيانات المستخدمين الى
الولايات المتحده بررت اللجنه الايرلنديه
لحمايه البيانات الغرامه وقالت ان ميثاب
وصلت بل واصلت نقل البيانات رغم حكم في
عام 2020 ابطل اتفاقيه لنقل البيانات بين
التكتل والولايات المتحده والغرامه التي
وصفت بالقياسيه اكبر من تلك التي فرضتها
لوكسمبورج على شركه امازون عام 2021
لانتهاك الخصوصيه والتي بلغت قيمتها نحو
800 مليون دولار
[موسيقى]
عن تعيين مدير تنفيذي جديد للمنصه خلفا له
اعتبره البعض محاوله لتعويض الخسائر
وتحسين اليات التواصل ليندا يا كارينو
الرئيسه التنفيذيه الجديده الملقبه بالمدق
المخمل لها تاريخ في العمل بالكيانات
الاعلانيه الضخمه خبراء راوا ان لكارينو
تاكوس خطط تويتر المستقبليه ومنها التركيز
على الاهداف الروحيه بغرض تعويض الخسائر
التي تكبدتها المنصه منذ تولي ماسك مهامه
والتي قدرت بالنصف والان من تويتر الى
انستجرام الذي يطمح لمنافسته افاد تقدير
نشرته وكاله بان انستجرام تخطط لاطلاق
التطبيق قائم على النصوص يتنافس مع تويتر
وقد يتم اطلاقه الشهر المقبل ووفقا
للوكاله يقوم خبراء ومهندس الشركه باختبار
المنتج مع المشاهير والمؤثرين وسيكون
منفصلا عن انستجرام ولكنه سيسمح
للمستخدمين بربط الحسابات
ببعضها الى هنا تنتهي اخبار الساعه لم
يبقى سوى التذكير بالعناوين
الهدنه تدخل حيز التنفيذ في السودان وحميه
يستبقها بالتعهد بعدم تراجع قواته المرشح
الرئاسي السابق سنان اوغان يتحدى
الانقسامات داخل تحالفه ويعلن دعم اردوغان
في جوله الاعاده وبعد هجوم بيلي جراد
روسيا تتهم اوكرانيا بالتخريب وقائد يفتح
النار مجددا على القاده العسكريين بعد
اسابيع من انهاء حاله الطوارئ حول كورونا
الصحه العالميه تحذر العالم من جديد وتقول
استعدوا للوباء المقبل
اترككم في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات